you know him you love him he's blasted
[Applause]
the challenger direct from out of the
wasteland he's bad he's beautiful he's
crazy it's
it's the man with no name
pops pops besides the fact this episode
gave me huge thunderdome vibes you may
have thought it didn't give much in the
way of new clues but trust me there are
some super revealing hints at where the
show is going now if you haven't seen my
episode 1 and 2 breakdown be sure to
check that out i'll leave a link to it
in the description and make sure to like
and subscribe because we aren't going to
be wasting any time let's get into it
the episode starts and ends with our
main character silhouetted against the
sun the roman god of the sun was soul
which is the same name marcus and the
mithraic call their god mother is on her
way to kill the serpent with a gun that
would make even james cameron blush but
as i theorized last week she won't go
through with killing this entity an
entity that is essentially her child on
her way she runs into father he's been
tasked by the supercomputer known as
trust to lead these mithraic slaves to
the serpent the plan is to have the
serpent eat them and have the explosives
attached to their chest detonate what
father and the others don't know yet is
that the serpent is an herbivore father
also reminds mother to be careful i'll
be cautious
and so should you
you haven't got your eyes we last saw
the necromancer eyes shoved down marx's
throat by lucius near the end of season
1. in this episode we can really see how
marcus has taken on superhuman-like
abilities like withstanding father's
shock stick and climbing these cliffs
with ease marcus believes that it's the
power of soul flowing through him that
has granted him this strength he'll
later tell decima that the snake skin he
found will be able to trap soul's energy
during the daytime so he can use it at
night i however believe these powers
come from the eyes he ingested and not
saw these eyes have somehow become a
part of him but at the same time it
might also cause adverse effects like
these veins cannot be healthy and i'm
surprised no one has been like dude you
should get that checked out in the tank
they commandeered from the atheists last
episode edessima picks up something with
huge energy heading their way something
that isn't airborne we never get
confirmation on who or what this is but
to me there are three options father
mother and a mysterious third being
we've yet to encounter this is hinted at
later in the show when it's found out
that the thing that killed those
colonists in episode 2 couldn't have
been the serpent mother tells father
that her tests on it indicate its scales
could not withstand the acidic ocean
waters so something big is out there
that can penetrate the acidic water that
we haven't seen yet lucius and the
others hear what appears to be the
serpent it almost sounds like a
necromancer siren that's because it is
the child of a necromancer father and
the methric run into marcus marcus wants
his many followers for his new church
and he's able to knock out father to
free them listen to these mechanical
noises as his veins move hinting again
that mother's eyes have somehow become a
part of him
with the prisoners freed there is one
holdout lucius he still believes marcus
to be a false prophet and would rather
endure being a prisoner than follow him
one of the more interesting side stories
this episode is that of paul campion and
vril vril brings them to marcus's
hideout for repairs from that gunshot
wound she sustained last episode and
there are some really interesting pieces
of information here that raise some red
flags first they set up that vril will
never be able to run faster than a human
the talk on this leg's gonna suck now
won't even be faster than a human this
has gotta foreshadow an event in the
future where she you guessed it can't
outrun a human she also tells campion
that her mom once broke her neck we can
assume this is decima however because
real is implanted with the memories of
decima's real daughter we actually don't
know if this neck breaking happened when
she was human or an android it might be
really crazy if it's later revealed that
decima killed her own daughter and
brought her back as an android as some
sort of repentance android vril says
that real real was often sad hinting
that the connection between her and her
mother was not good and then there's
this philosophical discussion about the
difference between pretending and being
i would like that
to not have to mimic but
to simply be we also get the start of
what seems to be a bit of a spark
between campion and vril campion will
later ask mother if there are other
robots that can give birth like her and
perhaps he's asking this for other
reasons i think the writers are setting
us up for an eventual confrontation
between vril and her mother in the
trailers we get this image and i'm
starting to believe this figure is for
real we also see campion use the device
marcus utilized to escape from their
wreckage i put my money on this being
used later in the season paul also finds
marcus's scalpel thereby confirming to
him that marcus is still alive he knows
this is marcus's from season one he also
knows that marcus isn't his real father
rather an atheist who has had his face
reconstructed to match it so paul really
has this dilemma that the episode ends
on there's this guy who killed his
father but at the same time he's
claiming to be soul's prophet and paul
is all about soul we also get
confirmation that decima and marcus are
a thing mother is accompanied by atheist
soldiers as she ascends the mountain
trust wants that serpent killed
believing it to be a threat to the
colony but i don't trust this computer i
think it knows a lot more than it's
putting on mother does her cross-shaped
pose something she'd normally do before
preparing to fly marcus will later do
this same pose again hinting at the
connection between these two especially
after he swallowed her eyes it's no
coincidence that mother tells cleaver
here why not get your eyes fixed
they belong to someone else didn't they
at the top of the mountain mother
decides not to kill the serpent when she
finds out it's not a meat-eater and it
wasn't one to kill those colonists in
episode 2. it poses no threat they'll
end up taking it to be studied in a cave
down by the atheist camp regardless
father still wants to kill it but won't
because it means so much to mother
father also says two grim lines of
foreshadowing
love
be the death of us all and to campion a
father should never outlive his son i
believe they're setting father up to
take over the million-year-old android
he's been putting together campion tells
father that if he breaks down that if
you ever break down they can just
transfer your mind to a different body
in my episode one and two breakdown i
talked about how this entity from the
trailers is likely the fully put
together ancient android and now i'm
thinking it will have father's memory
implanted into it campion also wrestles
with telling mother that marcus is alive
he's conflicted because if he were to
tell her it would likely mean the death
of real who he's grown fond of
well some atheists will burn equipment
if they think of mithraic has even
touched it father's revelation that his
blood regenerates this million-year-old
android sets him on the path for more
fuel blood the blood also killed the
radioactive plants that grew on its
surface and i can't help but think that
this will play an important role later
on sue also finds out that the serpent
is approximately six months old which
lines up exactly with when mother would
have given birth so she knows that lamia
is the mother paul is taken to talk to
trust in exchange for information about
marcus he'll give paul his pet mouse
something that went missing last season
paul even says this new mouse acts weird
and might not even be his real mouse
regardless trust informs paul that
within 24 hours marcus and his cohort
will be wiped out paul campion and holly
venture out to marx's camp with paul
wanting to warn marcus of the impending
attack meanwhile father's efforts to
restore the ancient android show that it
has started to develop a call or
membrane that covers a fetus similar to
those that cover the children when they
were born while traveling to the scrap
market father tells hunter that he's
saving a particular joke for someone we
know father loves his dad jokes but we
don't know who exactly he's saving this
for i think it's for when he brings the
ancient android online it's here hunter
almost gives away his soul pendant in
exchange for fuel blood but i found it
rather interesting father doesn't let
him go through with this perhaps knowing
how much it means to his son hunter
received this pendant back in episode 7
of season 1 and he'll give it to his
father for protection during his fight
in exchange for fighting billy the
industrial android father will receive 5
gallons of this fuel blood the fight is
pretty badass and proves that being
smart can win over being strong we also
briefly meet a potential new love
interest of tempus not exactly sure how
he'll fit into the story but they
generally don't introduce someone for no
reason back at the mithraic hideout
marcus tells the others he's done with
the formality of the old religion like
being called your eminence he also puts
his head through this skeletal starfish
symbolic of saul it's here he sees holly
campion and paul watching them notice
how vreel gets a fuel blood transfusion
to make up the blood she's lost even
though marcus did kill paul's real
father all signs point to paul joining
marcus campion doesn't care too much
about religion but it'll be real that
keeps him with marcus paul also knows of
this impending attack and if there are
three kids there it'll make that attack
far more complicated that's pretty much
it for this episode of raised by wolves
this season only has 6 episodes and
judging by how intense the trailers have
been i'm predicting things to pick up
quite quickly as usual i want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching make
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember you know him you'll love
him he's
pops pops
you